people have been talking about you and
Reese Witherspoon's pictures on the
right I don't even know if you saw this
and that they're awkward and you guys
won't put your arms around each other
you've been memes
Ashton Kutcher is explaining why it's
insane here's the backstory the actor
went viral last week with his your place
or mine co-star Reese Witherspoon why
well it had to do with how they posed
for photos at their films La Premiere
fans thought it was kinda awkward to see
Pals posing side by side keeping their
distance even Ashton's wife Mila Kunis
noticed it my wife called me she texted
recent eye together she's like guys
you got you gotta like you gotta like
act like you like
and I'm like what's going on but
Ashton's setting the record straight on
the chicks in the office podcast sharing
the actual reason why he refused to put
his arm around Reese here's the thing
okay all right here's the thing
if I put my arm around her and was like
all friendly with her I'd be having an
affair with it like that would the rumor
would be that I'm having an affair with
her right if I stand next to her I put
my hands in my pockets so there's no
chance that like that could be the rumor
the rumor is we don't like you yeah was
that a big draw for you to return to
this genre was that we need kind of more
of this levity and it was that it was
the idea of working with the queen did
working with Ashton for the first time
live up to your expectations Rhys I mean
it was so fun in this perfect movie so
we both felt responsible for making it
funny and better and endearing and real
and grounded and it turns out recent
Mila are actually good pals so there's
no bad blood here I'm better friends
with Mila because I'd known her for a
very long time it's just fun because
when you you know a girlfriend so much
you just like it was just fun to get to
know her significant other because I've
loved her for so long meanwhile Ashton
has lots to celebrate the new rom-coms
release do you remember the first night
we met
never stops being weird it's so weird
and his 45th birthday
[Music]
seems like the actors live in the dream
he wished for when he was just 20 years
old I wrote something down on a piece of
paper like my goal in life
and that was to move to Hollywood and be
in a movie and this is before I started
anything into the career and uh I still
carry it around with me that this day
and and I mean this is it's my dream
foreign